[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans le 7-8
loisirs ravi de vous retrouver pour ce
nouveau numéro dédié à vos idées sorties
tout de suite le sommaire de ce vendredi
19 janvier
devenez clown de théâtre grâce à la
compagnie dépasse rêve une troupe de
comédiens vous propose de vous essayer à
l'art de faire rire lors d'un stage le
27 janvier à la verrière l'un des
membres de la troupe nous parlera de
cette journée qu'est ce que la réalité
augmentée à quoi peut-elle servir
éléments de réponse grâce aux ateliers
scientifiques proposés à la commanderie
des templiers d'elancourt
nous ferons une découverte en images
lire ces voyages et disait victor hugo
et bien tout ce week-end se déroule la
nuit de la lecture dans toute la france
à la lanterne de rambouillet les
animateurs ont préparé un programme
spécial pour voyager en famille ou entre
amis mélanine nous ferons le point sur
les différentes activités plaisir va
accueillir le championnat de karaté
cadets minimes juniors des yvelines ce
week end au palais des sports
c'est la première fois que le karaté
club de la ville organise cet événement
à la clé pour les gagnants la
participation au championnat ile de
france pour ce club qui compte plus de
200 licenciés c'est un bon moyen de se
faire connaître
coup de projecteur et pour montrer
vraiment ce que c'est que le karaté à
savoir que
en 2020 il quand t'es pas faire partie
des jo et donc c'est une bonne chose et
montrez vraiment ce que c'est que le
karaté ses valeurs la compétition ce que
c'est différent parce qu'on fait des
katas et les combats ce week-end il va y
avoir une trentaine de clubs qui vont
venir
ah non leur meilleur compétiteur et je
pense que chez nous on va faire de bons
résultats
place aux pastels à villepreux françois
bonnel s'installe à l'hôtel de ville
jusqu'au 10 février
le visiteur peut découvrir une
cinquantaine de dessins inspirés des
tableaux des 17e et 19e siècles
l'artiste se concentre sur un détail
qu'il a grandi pour créer une nouvelle
oeuvre des toiles aux connotations
religieuses réalisées au pastel et au
crayon il a dévoilé un peu plus son
travail au micro de nicolas cyril auvity
donc il s'agit en fait d'une démarche
qui est à la fois je dirais à ses
documentaires puisque je suis très très
attaché au détail ont rendu justement
des effets que l'on retrouve dans ses
tableaux et en même temps c'est un vrai
travail d'interprétation puisqu'il ne
s'agit pas d'un simple copier coller
mais plutôt encore une fois d'une d'une
manière de revisiter des oeuvres du
passé qui me touche particulièrement
notamment pour les thèmes que qu'elle
qu'elle évoque
qui petit n'a jamais entendu cette
phrase arrête de faire le clown à la
verrière justement une troupe de
comédiens proposent de devenir un clone
de temps d'une journée un stage organisé
par le 27 juin le samedi 27 janvier par
la compagnie dépasse rêve patrick
pigeard comédien est membre de la
compagnie est avec nous bonjour bonjour
alors être tout simplement ce stage à
qui s'adresse-t-il on peut y accéder
quel que soit son niveau peut que soit
son âge
quel que soit son niveau c'est de
débutants confirmés sans aucun problème
est au niveau de l'âge il faut avoir
plus de 18 ans simplement c'est plutôt
adressées aux adjots on accepte tout le
monde sans aucun problème alors qu'est
ce que vous allez apprendre
on va apprendre à être soi même pas
jouer un rôle comme au théâtre classique
là on va partir à mende de choix et on
va apprendre à tenir un clown
alors justement apprendre à devenir un
clown alors comment ce qu'on apprend ça
c'est quoi la différence avec le théâtre
plus traditionnels vous l'avez dit c'est
pas vraiment un rôle en fait c'est
vraiment être soi-même développer son ca
sa manière de faire rire peut-être
développer peut-être le l'enfant qui
enclenche soit le laisser s'exprimer
librement
mayrand partir de soi plutôt que
d'essayer d'interpréter un rôle comme au
théâtre
alors sur quoi est ce que vous allez
accentue l apprentissage ajustements il
ya des têtes des techniques des méthodes
on va chanter parme sur le fait de ne
rien faire
d'exprimer beaucoup de choses en ne
faisant rien entendre disons le minimum
possible pour est arrivé à faire rire
mais surtout à émouvoir
on va chercher l'émotion principalement
à distance qu'est-ce que ça car ça fait
rire mais ça m'a aussi beaucoup c'est ça
c'est pas que faire rire c'est également
émouvoir
enfin moi je fonctionne pas mal par
l'empathie je pense que avec le public
n'ait compatit avec le public
le public on peut lui transmet n'importe
quelle émotion et par là on atteint
l'objectif
donc on va vous vous êtes vous même un
clone du court alors qu'est ce qu'il est
et s'il vous plaît dans le fait d'être
un plomb pourquoi je choisis ce type de
théâtre est particulièrement je pense
déjà pour ce que m'a dit quand j'étais
petit d'arrêter de faire le clown donc
ça m'a inquiété je pense plus grand à
l'être et il ya quelques années je
voulais j'ai commencé par une impro
théâtrale et je voulais chercher autre
chose et on entendait parler du clown
qui était à quelque chose de fabuleux
donc je voulais explorer cette voie là
ce que j'ai fait j'ai découvert
effectivement un univers où on pouvait
être soi même et on pouvait enfin
s'éclater ce jeu dépassé et se découvrir
en même temps l'idée c'est pas de
rentrer dans des cases c'est vraiment
laissé libre cours à sa créativité à sa
manière d'être sa manière de faire enfin
complètement et cherchait toujours le
détail chercher l'événement qui peut
arriver pour s'en saisir et le
l'explorer le les tirer au maximum
alors comment va s'organiser ce stage un
petit peu qu'est-ce qu'il faut prévoir
particulièrement faut prévoir une tenue
la plus décontracté possible
et après après vente de la boisson parce
qu'on va pas mal se dépenser quand même
il ya un échauffement au départ où on va
se décontracter commencé à lâcher prise
parce que le mais le maître mot sa came
de lâcher prise tout au long de la
journée et pour petit à petit la rive à
des exercices de clown où on va on va
complètement de lâcher prise
on va parler de la compagnie maintenant
des passerelles à chaque fois nous la
présenter alors elle a un an et demi à
peu près la compagnie on était tous des
improvisateurs et on avait besoin de
tout donc de créer un petit petit petit
cocon où on pouvait s'exprimer et donc
on fait du travail en entreprise ont
fait on va à l'hôpital de bullion
notamment faire le clown
à l'hôpital on fait des ateliers de nous
d'un procès des deux clowns des stages
de clown et on fait ça partout dans les
yvelines sur paris en france et au delà
on va au sénégal par exemple faire
au près d'une tht enfants ont vaguement
dans les écoles au sénégal honte aux
jeunes composez vous aider vous a déjà
bougé un peu partout en un an et nous
effectivement vous êtes quatre comédiens
c'est ça m'était 4 à la barre si on est
passé à 5
on est cinq ans tout et on n'est pas les
occupe effectivement parce que me bouge
un peu partout en france
particulièrement pour l'instant
prochaine étape la verrière le 27
janvier du coup c'est pas tout à fait
merci beaucoup patrick pigeard de nous
avoir parlé de votre compagnie de ce
stage donc que vous proposez on le
rappelle samedi 27 janvier à la verrière
tous les renseignements pour s'inscrire
sont sur le site internet de la
compagnie dépasserait merci beaucoup
patrick que jamais reçus découvrez les
sciences à la commanderie des templiers
d'elancourt des ateliers pour
expérimenter toucher manipuler et
surtout comprendre certains phénomènes
mercredi dernier nous avons suivi un
atelier dédié à la réalité augmentée un
reportage réalisé avec nicolas landry on
en fait une caméra ici qui va mesurer la
hauteur du sol instable et en fonction
de la hauteur il va mettre un jeu de
couleurs et bien vous voyez plus on est
haut
un bac à sable interactif qui changent
de couleur en fonction des formes quand
le réel rencontre le virtuel c'est le
principe de la réalité augmentée à
utiliser des casques ou des interfaces
plus transparente qui nous permettent de
voir le monde tel qu'il est mais en plus
on va rajouter par dessus des
informations virtuelles et numérique en
3d qui vont apparaître aux utilisateurs
ça peut être justement l'apparition d'un
personnage une création de fenêtres le
bac à sable on va dire à ce côté très
ludique
du côté direct en plus on a un peu
l'impression de se prendre pour dieu on
fabrique des paysages ont fait pleuvoir
donc il y avait ce côté très ludique un
outil pédagogique pour comprendre les
nouvelles technologies et leur
utilisation
car même si le futur semble loin il est
bien présent
on peut voir comment l'eau ruisselle sur
le terrain mais aussi stagne à
différents endroits et donc cette haute
voix elle reste après justement c'est
intéressant pour les enfants de voir
aussi comment ça peut fonctionner pour
voir eux ce qui peut en faire
ce qu'ils entretiennent aussi ils seront
certainement plus à mener encore que
nous à l'utiliser les apprentis
scientifiques sont attendus
régulièrement la commanderie des
templiers
d'autres expériences sont proposés pour
les prochains ateliers il faudra
apprendre à fabriquer un hologramme ou
utilisé de la peinture connectés
amoureux des livres le rendez-vous
junior de cette semaine et pour vous
mélanie ce week-end c'est la nuit de la
lecture
et oui c'est la deuxième édition et ça
se déroule un peu partout en france dans
les bibliothèques
c'est un rendez vous qui a été lancé par
le ministère de la culture et par celle
notamment ça se passe à rambouillet à la
lanterne plus exactement le pôle
culturel de la commune
ça s'appelle la nuit de la lecture
mignon on a décidé de commencer commencé
dès le dd le matin et dès l'après midi
jusqu'au soir à 23 heures il y aura un
enchaînement d'événements autour donc de
la lecture atelier d'écriture rencontres
d'auteurs
il y aura une soirée pyjama aussi le
soir une soirée pyjama et oui comme à la
maison quand on fait que les copains les
équipes de la médiathèque propose de
venir en pyjama avec son doudou et son
coussin la veillée se rassurer par
manuel magali qui est chanteuse
musicienne et raconteuse d'histoires et
une stéphane robin qui lui et glisse
guitariste jazz manouche la soirée
pyjama et pour les enfants de 5 à 10 ans
et ça commence à 20h30
alors là m'anime la manifestation de
manière générale est organisée pour les
enfants dès l'âge de 3 ans oui parce que
pour les tout petits c'est un théâtre
d'ombrés chinoises qui est proposé c'est
mené par trois bibliothécaires de la
lanterne il y a deux rendez-vous 16h et
17h et tout à l'argile vous parlez
d'ateliers d'écriture là c'est le
premier rendez vous de la journée totale
et c'est à destination des 8 11 ans à
14h on va programmer un atelier
d'écriture qui sera animé par béatrice
fontanel qui est une écrivain genèse qui
a publié une quarantaine d'ouvragés des
grands éditeurs gallimard jeunesse albin
michel jeunesse l'école des loisirs
ses thèmes privilégiés c'est la note
lui l'histoire les arts alors la soirée
pyjama est en entrée libre sans
inscription le théâtre l atelier par
contre d'écriture eux sont sur
inscription direction le site internet
de la lanterne pour ne pas rater le
rendez vous qui vous intéresse le 7-8
loisirs est maintenant terminé merci de
nous avoir suivis et n'oubliez pas que
ce dimanche 21 janvier c'est la journée
internationale des câlins alors vln y
aura montré l'exemple voilà donc un
câlin ça fait toujours du bien et en
plus même selon les scientifiques ces
réformes et sécurisant donc raison plus
pour ne pas s'en passer merci beaucoup
mais l'ami nous nous on se retrouve
vendredi prochain pour un nouveau numéro
et d'ici là je vous souhaite un
excellent week end
[Musique]